this video is sponsored by better
help more on them after the reaction
people citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Tera ericon alongside Andrew Flash Gordon what
is going on I love how you said that look look at
my t-shirt guys dead inside but Jolly AF I like it
yeah we're going to watch I almost said 22 Jump
Street but that is the name you were on you were
on track I think I was maybe going to say Jump
Street 22 22 Jump straight we're watching it you
guys so listen we're stoked I mean I actually am
excited cuz I really love the first one so leave
a like type a comment say how cool we are and
also don't forget ring the bell ring the bell
also thanks to prepper for helping us edit down
these videos also if you want to be super sexy
you need to get on the patreon because you could
syn up with your own copy watch the whole thing
with me and Andrew what that's insane Greg and
John offer exclusive highlights and watch alongs
over there on patre so get sexy that's what we
call you super sexy over there get with it are
you excited are you stoked what do you got
to tell the people Andrew how you so excited
I love the first movie and uh that line at the
end of the first one y'all going to college so
I'm stoked to go to college with Channing
Tatum and Jonah Hill let's do it let's do
it getting hyped just from the music yeah right
and those logos oh my God there's a previous I
love it oh you lucky you even graduated
this huh you want to be friends that was
my favorite part of the first one those two
yeah the chemistry all right all right do you
remember the lobster I don't remember that
you two sons of [__] are going to college
woo College here we go watch that whole movie
we just needed the recap and is associated
with water and femininity While y by contract
zoom out man this is BS I thought we're going
to actual College not online college dope car
think of this one from the first one they got
it I wonder how many times they improved that
scene that's the ghost Yost neelon biggest Traer
of illegal Goods in Metro City it's good actor
I teamed up with a Mexican cartel and they're
running all this [__] through the port what
the hell are we supposed to be buying I don't
know what are you doing I got a new identity
it's going to be killer I'm going need you to
improvise okay okay I don't want to improvise I'm
going to need you to improvise [__] improvise I
don't want to do it I need absolute silence
on the character dude you're in a movie of
improvising can you give me like a head start on
I need AB I need absolute Sil do a little Zip Zap
zop oh my goodness you had time
to do makeup that's great and
I love the western music too yeah
this walk serious right now oh I'm
sold [__] they sleepy what's up homie
Wolverine looks like Wolverine yeah that's
[__] man you're sleepy everyone saying the body
sleepy he like the Mexican Wolverine and when he
talking my name is Jeff
what tell about man tell that crazy adventure
you guys had I don't know what you're talking
about a man who you telling the story last
night that's me every time I try to do an
accent it was D and Diego and Swiper who was
that you choked out man B no man can't believe
the TKS I have to deal with these days makes
me miss the '90s good decade you want check
out the goods and shut up right where' you
find his Gringo man mfor his son's concert and
[__] and they're both so white what is it
guns drugs oh oh my God that legitimately
scared me ah it's my back oh almost
gave me like it felt like alien oh my
God whoa take him off guys they're cops
oh oh in here oh my God no not the car
damn bye-bye pretty girl I'm going to shoot
you in the face what are you doing oh Dam oh
all right man get up here I can't do that
climb around come on climb around yeah
it's really easy come all right you good
yeah all you got to do is walk now okay
okay get up here oh my God I have a
panic attack oh my gosh guys just get
here oh my
goodness Terminator you under I said pull
truck over whoa you owe me a card better
be a oh now I understand that Terminator
reference oh [__] oh my goodness they both
holy ow that was a cool shot is that a hickey
this uh this was actually uh an octopus related
incident nobody gave a [__] about the
Jump Street reboot when you first came on
this is meta I like it so now this department has
invested a lot of money to make sure Jump Street
keeps going well the commissioner convinced this
debacle happened because you weren't doing the
same undercover student thing you did the first
time always worse the second time around one gets
possessive the other runs away you begin a slow
painful unraveling is this foreshadowing yeah
what if we actually went into the Secret Service
and like tried to protect the White House I think
I'm saying we I'm GNA ask you to stop talking do
the same thing as last time okay keep it simple
I can't believe the Koreans bought their church
back I mean good thing there was an even bigger
abandoned church directly across the street yeah
that's convenient 22 Cher be right back across
the street just next door 23 ourselves not very
meta as you called it yeah way more expensive
for no reason look at Dixon's office oh you guys
did really well last time you earned it yeah you
[__] like Jump Street now hey girl hey 22
Jump Street is the lick and I got a big ass
raise to babysit you two again I love how met
this is this is great 21 Jump Street and Korean
Jesus come on Korean Jesus is right there that's
Vietnamese Jesus you racist Sac religious sack
of [__] look at that Vietnamese Jesus just
dripping swag good hey hey look alive boys yo
jenko same assignment we're going back to high
school your ass look like you're about 50 you
going to MC State they look 50 somebody's out
there they cooking up a new drug it's ader all
mixed with ecstasy mixed with God knows whatever
sounds great I want to try that wi wi no you dumb
mother WiFi stands for work hard yes play hard yes
they get laser focus for about 4 hours of studying
and then they party like it's goddamn 1999 who's
this that's Cynthia Watts he was a student at MC
State took some Wi-Fi got locked out of her dorm
ended up falling off the wo o yikes that's her
buying drugs on campus and that's the dealer find
him and we find a supplier it is so refreshing to
have a case with a black victim we care so much
more because she's black H We Care equally it's
a tie really oh my God no we're not if it was
a white person I wouldn't even care one less
cracker ass cracker to worry about oh my God
why every time you speak I want to throw the
up my goodness I love every time ice cube disses
him it never gets old yeah yeah cuz most of the
time it's warranted anyways what's up bro High
School right school oh so tight oh this is never
seen someone so excited to live in the dorm yeah
right oh dooke that's a that looks like okay oh
yeah gross it's really incredible how many so dorm
rooms look so alike yeah just in all different
schools I mean Bean back chair hilarious shirt
that signals we drink alcohol M I love bear pong
some bakon machine that my mom got me you don't
understand how it works I love the titling in
this Q-tips be back chair a comfort that I will
not wash for the next 6 months they are clearly
ready for college what up fellas we across the
whole neighbors oh twins's up man yangs man what
going on man Yang what's up did you say the yangs
yeah Dad Chinese man my mom's not Chinese she's
black we're brothers too you like one of yall
older you got crows feet into your eyes man I mean
well even if you're a little older that's cool
girls here love old the D especially doing spring
break oh my gosh I love that kind of want
something that's a little deeper reallys
deep the same is amazing that's crazy
we have that brother connection too I
wonder if they do that in real life on accident
quing Bo that's complete improv yep you
took a bullet from me all right I didn't
it sucked I do it again no way it's my
turn I owe you life dead goe bathroom
oh wow oh hello I'm not going to take
a [__] the entire time I'm here I
know stop just exhausted from inventing Facebook
or whatever website people already use so go to
all Cynthia's classes and activities ask around
about the drug and find out who the dealer is
dude in human sexuality do you get to or do you
just get to watch people neither probably just
watch adult films I've got a first impression
for you oh y'all like psychology Tracy Mor my
God nobody wow you looking for some Wi-Fi
yeah man be sick go to the police station
walk in and ask your captain to see the
evidence from cuz you're a AR I think
you're mistaken you're literally
wearing your badge I didn't look
down you guys play football no this is actually my
laptop yeah I'm taking notes
right now I'm kidding it's a
football what has been the result of the War on
Drugs well it's definitely harder to get drugs
the average price of cocaine has dropped 70% in
the last 30 years then your dealer is probably
selling you some pretty steep on [__] cheap okay
college is a wonderful place this is where you
get to decide who you actually are instead of the
person that you're clearly pretending to be right
now why are you saying this stuff that's
exactly the answer I wanted Mr McQuade I
want you to question what I'm saying this
is the basis of this whole course he did
it even though he didn't understand I can
really say whatever I want George Washington
was a black lesbian the Eiffel tow made a
they can't fire me I'm indestructible I'm
sleeping with two of my students her and her
actually am this is an awesome class sign me
up the only way you can fail this class is by
not becoming who you truly are please respond
to my text oh god oh man uh we just need
you guys to fill in the blank in a sentence
that we're going to set up so it'll go like
this oh I'm so hungry I wish I had a tampon
okay let's try it one more time oh
I've got to get home so I can feed my
boner what would that girl's in my side class
go talk to her you come talk to her with me
stop being go talk to her go like dude you
scored with Brie Larson last film you know
how to talk to you know what's up was a high
school but you still I talked to we're in the
the same site class oh yeah pills pills pills
a sign of the times that rhymes Amanda binds
Cynthia that girl who died did you know her
she lived across the hall from me so what why
do you care so much I'm writing a um slam poem
wouldn't it be better to just to like plan the
stuff out ahead of time and make sure it's
funny and then not say it in front of that's
not the point of impr stand up comedy that's
probably what you should do cuz that stuff's
funny anybody have anything they want to
share let's see what you get do you really
do poetry improvisor I do and I will you got
somebody what oh No uhoh Slam poetry yelling
angry waving my hands a lot specific
point of view on things Cynthia
Cy Julia Roberts Julia
robs Rich herd gear Cynthia you're dead you
are dead oh my God that's for Cynthia he's
dead Standing Ovation I don't have a
single lead I do I hear you can get
Wi-Fi on campus anywhere 24/7 product
placement Doritos baby best flavor well
we need help we need to consult
an expert yo dud you got a minute
got oh that was funny that makes sense cuz that's
that's what they did to him in the first movie
[__] you are looking fit a you should get
some tips from this guy he's looking good oh
Dave Franco I'm liberated totally you know they
gave me a it's awesome you guys want to see it
take your word for it Eric's seen it Eric's been
all up in that [__] A that right Eric you guys
got to get me the out of here I'm Eric's [__]
no you're not yes I am I'm your [__] it's a
lesson to y'all don't get in trouble and go to
jail I am such a [__] when Aunt Flo shows up
it bleeds so much it's crazy oh my it's like
the elevator door is opening in The Shining
I've never seen that movie but I understood that
reference yes I know but we can't see his face we
don't know who it is we don't know who it is I'm
Smith my parants are full of Duty yeah that's you
you sort of sound like that that doesn't sound
anything it doesn't sound anything like me did
you even bother to look at the picture yeah
huh there's a reflection right here oh find
the tattoo find the dealer good eye I don't know
I do a lot of stupid tattoos to drunk kids you
remember that stupid tattoo I've never gotten
a tattoo you guys wait did those twins did they
say boom did they say that I can't remember did
they or I don't know maybe they didn't maybe I'm
wrong I don't think they did I might have did it
on a football player I think I know know exactly
who he's talking about you you little walk on
can't like move around oh it's going to be so
funny watching Jonah Hill to football [__] dude
I'm so sorry it's all right man don't worry about
it man e ow I got it I got oh my goodness dude I'm
sorry I got my Q-tip in your meat bro oh man I got
my I got my meat in your Q-tip oh it's w it's
Wyatt Russell Kurt Russell son oh it's like a
meat cute it's like a meat are they in love right
now it seems like it it's a meat cute sandwich me
and this guy are having a meat cute he looks
he looks a lot like Kurt Russell too Brad Brad
wait uh yeah yeah Brad I'm z z nice to meet you
nice to meet you too man oh yeah he he so looks
like oh my gosh they're in love yeah he has his
eyes like 100% I did not know that that was his
son who love walk on day
now tattoo if you see that safety lineup That
D though hit me quicker oh yeah I didn't know
you had Wheels like that bro it's funny cuz
he's my brother so he's getting Jelly we have
this Rush party I thought you know you could
come by and meet the guys it'd be really fun
you too you can come to see also I said a bunch
of stuff earlier that you didn't acknowledge so
great and he didn't even acknowledge he said
that I love it enough to confirm that rooster
has that bazooka tattoo is he wearing
a joker up dude same puka dude [__]
dude I knew we were going to be connected
just like that guys tired together and get
married that's the best line
right there nothing's going to top
that I've been to so many parties where that's
been me I'm just like sitting there awkwardly
in the corner awkwardly in the corner I'm like
nobody likes me so rooster oh yeah no uh we'
met before oh really I don't remember that at all
you must have a really plain face n it was so nice
chatting nice to meet you what are you doing dude
serious right now you you're being weird you've
been weird I'm wondering if it's it's actually
meat cute guy that might be selling the drugs
you think it's him you think it's him with the
tattoo yeah that it might be a little reversal
we didn't see coming yeah probably I mean just cuz
it seems like it's so obvious that it's the other
one my gosh I miss so much come on let's go
all right yeah we saw on the truck scene he's
clearly not capable of doing that yeah there's
no way I'm just going to go home I don't know
parkour so yeah this is me um I'm an art major
okay not a model major yeah I love to be alone
just love when you're sitting there in a room
and you're just there with your thoughts and
you're like oh my gosh I'm alone anyone ever
love me or whatever and like he's so good he's
so good at improv if you don't want to be alone
tonight we are going to go hang out at the art
building if you want to come okay okay that's
me when someone's like want to go see some art
okay okay okay I expect tonight would go in a way
that you wouldn't expect but what I didn't expect
was tonight do I see a two peeking through on
his oh I I didn't so you guys hang out here a
lot I wasn't being a we'll look again oh my God
he's in this why is that actor remember the show
um love or on Netflix see how he has a line
on his yeah that I did see whoa uh get out of
town I guess Channing T's making up for the
the fact he didn't go to college so he's kind
of living vicariously through his undercover job
right now totally feel like they both are oh it's
only two I thought it was late do you want to come
in it's only two I thought it was late are you
kidding I mean Tara and I are old so like yeah so
10:00 is late very late go post bro you guys might
want to hold on cuz this [__] is coming down
oh oh what is this is that the one what's that
right there oh it's my old high school it's not a
boom okay so it is it's it's Wyatt Russell he has
it you called that all you got to do is join the
team yeah yes yeah dude uhoh uhoh look that's me
is it the one no that's the one oh it is boom boom
shs well now you really got to play on the team so
you can get closer to uh oh you hey good call now
he's got to F out of out of love with his with his
bro his dude bro and now you shall be accused
of seeing the film yeah what's up with it how
you doing hi he got to sleep with that model and
her underwear well it's still early that was this
for you fun for me it's a good time yeah right
I enjoyed it yeah this is why I don't drink huh
you're like the loudest climaxer I've ever heard
look I I just want you to know I'm not like a hit
it and quit it type fella H is she a hited in
I mean you're cool with just hooking up yeah I
mean no I mean I'm glad you said something cuz I
don't even know if I like you when I'm sober no I
know was great good you're good at it and I'll
text you 3 to 5 minutes or something all right
3 to five minutes oh boy one of us got laid last
night sh don't wake up my bluing on the red eye
hasn't gotten a wink of sleep talking missionary
we're talking when I'm on top and she's on her
back a she's smart she's an art major I will give
you some DB SM are you crazy are we going to talk
about how weird you were today with Dixon look
I don't think the tattoo means what you think
it means I I mean for all we know a lot of people
could have that tattoo this tattoo this absurdly
specific tattoo yeah in that specific area too
zuk has a tattoo we've been looking for this
tattoo for days do you understand this means zuk
is the dealer I really want you guys to hang out
he's in denial Tera yeah cuz he loves him guys Ken
you just give us some space we're really trying to
figure something out we need to focus okay not
going to have a trouble focusing man yeah man
those crispy trees got mad wifi in them oh no
I've eaten six of these oh God who showed you
Wi-Fi yeah man Cynthia gave us a buttload
and in the exchange we wrote hologic paper
for oh damn you feel anything no do you feel
anything no but I have a super high tolerance
oh I'm so focused I so Focus to I love
that they're on this Mission like this it's
great this is awesome like performing
The Sober got to be so difficult too
yeah maybe they just slam like
seven Red Bulls Maybe yeah not
B going Mission Impossible you know it's not Lan
safety
awesome I like that epic music to slow down going
up nothing's happening is making
the glass cutting sound that's
no fun at all it's okay you're on
drugs we'll forgive you let's do
this should have done the laser cutter
yeah don't to Dr some I don't time to prove
zuk's a dealer qu obviously right I mean the
guy is the guy is all time the guy let's
be honest I mean like he was open up beer
cans with his eyeballs you got he's
got to make it for that he's got to
m r poor Doug I got a bad feeling about
this guy dude I was talking to him for a
second he's got a big mouth I feel like
whole thing you know it's interesting in
that class where the teacher said you can be
anything you want there it said Star Wars in
the back and then he just said I have a bad
feeling about this which is a line in all
the Star Wars so little had a Trope there love
that sh I'm trying to hear them be nice about
me I think somebody up there above the Star Wars
it said Coca-Cola and at the party
they were all drinking Coca-Cola
sponsors oh no that last one
was not really covered very
well the other ones were but that last one was
not he just throws his backpack into a
tree why do you think he saw us no you're
just paranoid because we're about to trip
balls no I'm paranoid because he could be
dangerous we're fine look we made here oh oh
waa dud that scared the crap out of me that
me whoa oh this must be them getting
hazed because they decided to accept
them yeah exact exactly yeah for
sure they're going to kill us
J where you going oh they are
tripping such balls that would
be terrible having a back trip I
think we are tripping my side's
so much scarier than yours and they
really did up the budget in this film
yeah I finally got my
Lambo
I love that song don't go oh my God no
stay here stop it you're dragging me down
why would you drag me down it's okay just stay
in the buddy system get out of the car get out
of the car under knes you already know don't
you what oh it's definitely hazing yeah open
your mouth it's going to be like tequila
yeah yeah exactly a vodka to vodka welcome
to the Frat Boys if you don't make it through
tonight you're dead to all of us rooster light
the torch I want to know how anyone's liver is
still intact if you were in a frat or a sority
yeah oh God I I would literally just be puking I'd
be puking vomit I wouldn't be P I would
be projectile vomiting you'd be it'd be
like the Exorcist yes exactly like it
we watch that together right sure did
yeah and they're doing this while drugged up
yeah I'm I'm happy for Chaine Tatum
he's living out his dream right now
he finally got to go to college well if
you think about it the first movie like
Jonah Hill got to go to the prom and be
popular and now this movie it's for him
but I mean I guess for Jonah Hill he
got to sleep with the really hot walk
yeah nice I can't this is disgusting I can't
do this anymore and now for my favorite event
I'm not doing I'm not doing this is what we
have to do to win their trust is supposed to
be fun it's fun for you it's not fun for me I
don't know maybe we should just go our separate
ways maybe we should just just investigate
different people split up did you really
just say that yeah remember the foreshadowing
in the beginning of the movie they called it
Nick Offerman called it don't like the idea of
doing stuff separately we can still investigate
together now it'll be an open thing you want an
open investigation this is great this is great
the subtext yep you want an open investigation
okay so I guess I'll catch you later then you
okay let's hug it out you can't hug me right
now money for cab no I don't need money for
a cab this is really emotional right now yeah I
I really like this scene a lot City well I guess
he rejected it right yeah I guess you're right
drops back nice we've got time for one last place
damn solid looks like MC st's got a
new power couple Z and McQuay what
get around you man I can't jump got broken oh my
goodness bro time [__] he's just
sitting around watching them oh
is that is that the girl he hooked up
with I think so or oh no he's testing
the music CU well they said one of you is going
to get him don't come in I'm having with a human
woman human woman hey oh his parents I love them
it's parents weekend wonderful you're dating
someone yeah they're definitely dating Doug Maya
these are my parents so this is the girl hi I'm
Annie I'm your new mother-in-law my goodness
well my parents are here too mine H Ice Cube
oh no yikes Dad this is Doug a guy that
I'm dating how's your classes going Doug
you're in the neighborhood and to be fair
he did not know he didn't know nor did Ice
Cube say to him hey my daughter goes here
do not sleep yeah he did not specify that
yeah he should have to be fair I'm sorry
that's not Jonah Hill's but Que laas in
this oh was that I didn't even I was just
looking at Ice Cube's reaction how did you
two meet we met at a poetry slam and then he
stalked me back to my dorm room stalked her
uh oh and then we hung out and we watched a
movie actually we watched it a couple times
yeah kind of black man do to get us some water
around here give the give the guy some water
he's black he's been through a lot where are you
from originally I'm straight out of compon but
my husband's from Northridge oh we're not too
far from either those three give godamn string
beans I like fruit but this pork [__] he's
under a lot of press at work what's up play
want go to the movies break your M break your
oh my God I wonder if he had to nail this the
first time yeah I had to cuz they're like we
can't how many turkeys or chicken can they go
through uhoh sorry dude is that it he sells drugs
WiFi you know you can always tell me something if
you want to get it off your chest you know I'm
always here for you right what are you trying
to say no nothing everything that happened with
Cynthia and Wi-Fi this is not the time to do when
he's spotting you but it's good for the movie I
have a friend who knows a guy ATC and they want
me to make a tape and I want you to be on it
with me that was quite a reveal it's going to
be our shot we're like the dynamic duo bro we're
like Batman and Robin not Captain America and the
Winter Soldier do you understand that reference
I do cuz I watched that show and he was on that
show yeah the whole time I didn't know he's Kurt
Russell's son yeah you really think I can make it
at UMC you could make it into the Hall of Fame
oh well that's you you're going to be in like
the anals of football history dude you could
make it into the anals of football history
too I just don't understand what his problem is
with you specifically I don't Jesus that makes
no Doug why does my dad have your phone
number I don't I don't know maybe the
school directory or something let's
do something that would distract us
so we don't have to think about him
oh my God his is it okay if we just
talk okay you're a genius dude are
you sure it's not too much though no
Sho best video ever they should post that on
YouTube get a lot of hits yeah another star wi
Jin buy me a beer oh my God they're like brothers
I can't believe we've been talking all night oh
my God it's 8:00 got class you can help yourself
to whatever you need and um yeah I'm so sorry I
don't know how people go to class at 8:00 p.m. at
night ridiculous you guys High School I started
class at 7:40 p.m oh a am I thought she said
am oh she did say am okay I thought oh it's the
morning now stuff wasn't meant for you was meant
to be private so am I supposed to just sit here
and act like I hear every one of your problems
you're more messed up than Cynthia was and she
went to the school shrink three times a week
why but he gave her a ton of pills and [__]
maybe he could give you something oh she would
be a good psychiatrist or therapist this that
character is it going to be a character we've
already seen what do you think you've been
predicting correctly I'm like the psychiatrist
is it is it pat oh is it that Psych is it that
psychologist class remember the psych psychiatric
teacher that they the one who was talking like
Tracy Pat yeah the one who's talking like Tracy
Murphy oh yep you're right totally called it now
now I shall be accused of seeing the movie
you think you're the first Partners to come
in here looking for help only to try to run when
you're first faced with talking with me you know
we were Partners a relationship is something that
requires constant work which is what I thought we
learned in high school so you are high school
sweethearts I mean they technically are yeah
I just feel like sometimes he's not even trying
anymore sometimes I like to have the participants
make physical contact why don't you hold hands
okay I'm not doing that okay reach out your hand
he's literally reach ing out for you you won't
hold my hand I'm not doing that I kind of needed
to do it you got to interlock it though if you
don't interlock it this is like the [__] hand
move you got to what I want to be able to have
is this is is this I want to be able to have
that that same thing in a are you embarrassed
of your partner no not at all okay and why
the are you guys ganging up on me gang up on him
that's such a thing that happens in therapy with
with relationships I teach you about a principal
called embedding look at the facts matter fact
zuk has the tattoo he knew Cynthia he's still
talking with yeah what did you say embedding
was embedding is our tendency to latch onto the
first bit of information that we're offered and
over looking or even ignoring contradictory
information recomend you can leave the room
just get the out the first time we saw the photo
of Cynthia buying Wi-Fi Dixon said this guy's the
dealer everything we've done in thought has been
based on that fact oh oh and we've ignored all the
other Clues oh and it's what if Cynthia was the
dealer wa wow we have something really really to
tell you about oh god oh he's ready to shoot him
what the is going on this is what the is going
on the plot thickens oh [__] oh [__] oh
my God that delayed the response is so great
Channing Tatum has the best reactions ever I'm
sorry so good literally yo this is the best thing
ever okay Jonah Hill owns The
Improv but he owns the reactions
yeah you actually high five sh for your daughter
holy [__] oh my God this is it's really not that
funny I just want to say that it was bizarre not
to share the fact that your daughter went to MC
State that's what we said yep what if captain
gets to punch you in the face one time I got
something way better than that oh oh man we have
to stop treating this like it's exactly the same
as last time and we got a bigger problem no more
money in the budget what I thought we had klette
KL you mean car blanch we did have car blanch
not no more you got that expensive Chase in the
beginning oh my God it's so met up uhhuh shit's
expensive I got them $800 shoes and you can't
even see them up and you had a couple SE scenes
with my daughter look I apologize about the zuk
thing what if he's like hey got all this wi-fi
let's sell it okay great you apologize what's
that worth man now we have no lead what are we
supposed to do now police work yeah kids don't
check out books anymore right I don't think
they know how to read oh book place library
book place a book I don't think I've ever heard
that a book place you wa up dud hey dude where
are you oh this like reminds me of when he was
late to the Peter Pan thing like where are you
exactly you can do this alone I'll be back in two
hours you got this just go to the book place I
guess he made it whereas Jonah Hill didn't make
it to the heang to the in like two minutes well
we'll suspend disbelief Place think if somebody
wants to show us their operation at least be on
time what do you think the psychology teacher or
oh it's this guy oh I do miss today is what he
doing when people did normal drugs what is
this is he going to dress up Mexican style
again yeah I wonder well he can't because the
guy would recognize him right away know right
away oh now getting it getting
it getting it getting it and
he hangs off with a touchdown these two are and
a he's playing in a game he told you that can
you shut it what's wrong with those classic
drugs from the [__] oh oh oh oh [__] here
you have a sh goes right there okay he's about
to meet up with the supplier hey sh check that
out uh oh God go tackle him you're interrupting
a a really Stellar what the hell is going on
it's okay it's just a couple of yo what the
did you just say you said you were sucking his
di it's 2014 [__] you can't use yeah exactly
homosexual maybe and if you know the person you
might be able to call them a queer if they have
a great humor but I don't I'm sorry he took one
human sexuality class he thinks he's Harvey Milk
I understood that reference Sean Penn why can't
you just use your head for once oh you want me
to use my head fine oh you [__] are all
under arrest where's your gun what do you
have guns what no I don't we have guns uh they
didn't think that plan through very well this
way it's fast oh damn hurry up okay whoa that
was awesome come I can't jump down I'm not a
Spider-Man yeah buddy do look like
Spider-Man that looks awesome that's
the car back amazing almost as cool as
the Camaro well they did say the budget
is gone so yeah makes sense please do
something about how slow this thing's
going oh [__] watch out watch
out oh we can't destroy any more stuff we can't
waste any more of the Department's money we don't
have a budget o amazing that's how you get money
out of an ATM you just run it over I'm just going
to run it over next now I'm going to start doing
that dope I got to offer the scholarship to play
football here next year you can't be a cop and
stay here and play football with Zoo just when
I'm on the football field and I'm diving for a
pass I feel like I can C when I'm with you it
just feels like you hold me down oh damn dang
he's never going to be able to fly with you on
the football field sadly dude the brid are out
oh cuz he pull pulled the cord you got to jump
you got to jump jump jump jump oh boy I did say
earlier it's going to go down yeah woo there it
goes that's a weird thing to celebrate yeah
is that a college thing that I don't get
Maybe underr hey I'm an officer right just
take me and I'll explain later I don't know
hey who's this doent didn't doing wait wait
wait what are you doing what are you doing I
decided for you stick with football this is
actually sad I didn't think I was actually
going to be moved like this I was just expecting
comedy yeah they do a good job of delivering it
well and setting it up really nicely to be
like oh that's sad hey Maya Angelou thanks
for lying to me wait did she find out he's
a c uh I don't know we could we got there
quickly yeah this is going to be
great cuz he's going to realize
we're too much alike and he's going to
miss his friend just wondering we have
identified and arrested one Dr Carl Murphy
Oh Wi-Fi residue throughout his office and
had a close personal relationship with the
deceased feel like it wouldn't be him that
was a setup you're not supposed to thow
rocks what you're not supposed to throw
rocks he is mad inside the lobster for
one person that that sounds good sounds
delicious love Lobster I would
get down on some lobster right
now hey you want to do anything else other than
about today this is what we do man dude come on
no don't be afraid why don't I love that I don't
remember the lobster scene from the top but I
love that he's trying to do all the things that
they did yes to try to recreate the same Bond
it's perfect why don't I remember the lobster
was it a delete uh I don't it might have been
I mean I remember a lot of the first movie I just
don't remember that maybe it was a deleted scene
maybe people let us know in the comments like
you just guys you just forgot we blanked it o
are they going to meet in the yard right now I
believe they are oh that was cool that's a great
turn transition just came to see how you are I'm
the happiest I've ever been so I'm just having
a great time with myself glad you're having a
good time with yourself I'm a solo artist now
like Beyonce I used to have the other Destiny's
children but now I'm just a a lone Superstar like
Justin Timberlake no more in sync no more how
are you I'm pretty great I just chill and you
know how chill zuk zuk's such a chill guy just
say you miss each other and make out already I
just wanted to say that like I was thinking about
the case I was worried they got the wrong guy for
it that's what we were saying yeah I looked
into the ghost background and I saw that he
pays tuition for a student at MC State you
think the ghost could be the supplier's dad
maybe I think it's zuk or H I don't know maybe the
other guy the The Jerk guy yeah the other football
player red hair spiky oh yeah I I don't know who
else cuz we haven't really met any other their
characters maybe the twins I don't know someone's
bringing a [__] ton of that stuff down to PTO
Mexico for spring break we could go down there
what about school and football and I have time
offerto Mexico nice going to his
homeland from the character at the
beginning that he was yeah one of these
babies a grenade why are you going to
put that is not the place you want to put
that Mr spot the music cues in this are so
great one finger
H yeah get it did you not see that I
was going first damn that is awesome
wild oh wow mad
WiFi jeez
I wish I had that backpack I wish I had that
backpack that backpack full of money would
really help me out oh the roommate ah that makes
that makes sense ah that makes sense so much sense
I'm sure rewatching it too like looking at we
would have like all these kids hooked on Wi-Fi
then you're going to bring it back to your Turf
and you're going to sell the [__] out of it
sell [__] [__] out of it why don't you
sell those old classic drugs from the '90s
Like Cocaine from the '90s okay so yangs you'll
take my dead roommate spot oh the twins are you
kidding me Yang are you high of course yeah put's
your guns down guns down Doug my name's not Doug
it's Schmid and guess what cops oh my God yeah
everybody knows you guys look like the stars of
a cop show called Hawaiian dads these actors are
so good with their reactions I love it we have
way more guns than you drop your that's a good
point this really your entire plan or maybe we
had a far more elaborate plan maybe my partner
has a tracking device in his pocket right now
may what you have track Dev I don't have it's
the one thing you were supposed to remember
the [__] dumbest possible thing is letting
two cops blah blah blah while other cops are
getting in position to bust their [__]
in oh so you mean I brought the tracking
yeah what's up now huh such a real argument
that's in [__] yeah spring break yourself
we shoot in Jump Street oh ah his BR the nerd
alerts we love him don't do it leather face
oh protect that backpack at all cost save
it for Terra please I need it you know what
happens in a shootout they always kidnap the
girl not always Mercedes you're coming with
me [__] please I ain't going nowhere
with you oh oh that hurts shot me in my
foot move move faster now my time you shot me
in myam foot Mercedes just took my dad that
way okay we're on it going go by the way you
look really attractive that would have been
great Lamborghini yeah baby dream car police
police here huh ow what do we do uh we just
spit up you okay with that yes he's strong
enough now and I need to drive your faster
on foot what I don't get to drive the lambo
no go come on let's go [__] about the lambo
just go I can't let him go you're going
to have to take him take care of her okay
how do you drive this thing you got to let her
drive you bro it's true I'm sure chaning Tatum
was actually really sad about that in real
life like dude can we just switch this please
bit it does make sense to have Jonah Hill save
Ice Cube yeah just got to accept him that's one of
best let me you get
crazy bmobile that is a good analogy
see people I'm not the only one who
makes comic book references he's the only one
on this channel just kidding is enough you
need
cool awesome well done smooth get over here I'm
handcuffed hole a nice parking job I'll be right
back I got to go he should probably be taken to
the hospital he got shot in the foot whoa nice
tackle get your fre hands
off how the hell well I guess you would find
him cuz he's got the pink backpack yeah then
you better fight like two men hey hey
oh damn uhoh yeah but is zuk going to
come in and help him he's his brother yeah
I'm not going to fight a girl so just stop
shouldn't matter have you thought of me as
a person instead of a woman you would hit me
and not feel bad about it oh wa girl was this
guy just randomly sitting there watching he
looks drugged out too he's so high oh waa
is there blood in my eye blood in my eye
oh that's a little better that's a little
better is this their meat cute no what no
what were you doing what am I doing why did you
try to kiss me I try to kiss you yes you did oh
you're so weird yeah OHA you haven't wented to
kiss me the whole time I never once wanted to
kiss you never no oh my God you gave me kiss
me eyes no I didn't the eyes were eyes I just
got punched in the face eyes they weren't
kiss me eyes this guy is just sitting here
like what's I love it I'm going to give you
an out by punching you in the face okay and
then we're going to go back to fighting and
we'll Pretend This Never Happened cuz I feel
so awkward oh it's so great zuk help him yeah
blow up doll help him out help him out oh maybe
he doesn't need zuk's help whoa cool nice oh wow
it's like I'm on channy Tatum oh oh nice cool that
girl's probably so drunk she's not even feeling
anything oh W she's a dancer that School whoa
awesome oh my God oh my God and then they make
out is that a plastic imagine how about
this you want a little fun is that yes
oh vient
I'm I'm impressed you caught up to me you
probably haven't run that fast you played
stick ball in the field behind old pop wiggle
be's sweet shop I have a clean shot Schmid and
don't take the shot maybe I want to take
a dirty shot kind of like the dirty shot
you took on my daughter you didn't know didn't
take a dirty shot with your daughter we talked
a lot and we care about each other all the good
qualities you have I could feel inside of my
don't take the shot taking the shot
I'll take the nobody take the shot is
that Maya behind him I thought I saw Maya
behind him yeah now Maya what oh you go
handle the ghost he's on the roof I'm on
it I got it oh good job on the cups baby
girl oh he's running out of steam it's me it's
me I love when they do these transitions from
the sidebars yeah dude you were right that
Lambo was just can't hear that right now
it's a shitty made car it's not good it does
ride too low to the asphalt for my tastes got
go we have to wait for P I missed it did they
say oh oh he's going to take a bullet for him
maybe y oh well that's what that's that's
what happened last remember completely miss
the other shoulder yeah in the exact spot in
the other shoulder he completely mistimed it
nice call back I tried to take a bullet for
you man but you didn't not the thought counts
it's taking the bullet cover me I'm going
to go long okay oh this is where he they
get to I wish you could ride fly with
me and I feel like they're doing that
now whoa later Wolverine nice Bye by terminate
ha whoa nice how's he able
to hold on he's got a gunshot
amazing is he going to make it I think he
will after all those fails he's got to have a
success they're going to fly
together
yeah well earned nice I did it you do
I couldn't leave you hanging man what
are you talking about I was fine I had it oh oh
no oh my God I got you oh damn and they
said they don't have the budget clearly
not for stunts that for stunts they do they
do I guess you could drop them in the water
you don't hold me down man you lift me up
literally and figura Hey listen there's a
grenade in my shorts can you reach it
oh yeah that's right I forgot about
that is it oh that's great Oh no
I got it in my mouth say something
cool when you throw it something
cool hey nice no not the money not
the money we need the money oh feel so
alive feel so alive for the very first
time let's party Like It's 1999 dude I miss
you so much man I miss you too you're like a
tiny little flower seed I was I was clenching
you in my fist but a flower and K growing in a
fist fire I'm in thank God this is what I've
always wanted just me and you buddy yay dude
we're even about to arm thing okay right what
what do you want to do all right just just get
it over with oh my god really raise my arm I
don't want you to hit the bone two three oh no
oh my goodness no for your next mission you two
sons of [__] are going to medical school what
what yeah nice I can't wait time foreign
exchange students awesome in Russia in
Russia hey 24 jumpster I love it next assignment
a semester at C This is So Meta I love it ready
art school I actually want to see all these
movies me too veterinary school she may look
any different to you no set oh hey I got new
glasses yeah may just got some new glasses
man God damn definitely looks the same do
this oh my goodness I mean sometimes there
are different castings for the same character
really glad you're back what are you talking
about what contract dispute I've been here
the whole time how about a Flight Academy
don't be afraid to yeah give me some Top Gun
[__] you're Jump Street right Richard greo
he was in the original 21 Jump Street oh
[__] video game video G I want to play
this game we should react to the game yeah at
least the cool car works in the game I would
buy that lunchbox no you would buy the the pink
backpack as long as it comes with the money in it
don't sh my dick sign 6 hours of makeup we're
getting too old for this [__] nice oh God
whoa they're pulling out all the stops love it
Three Amigos or the Two Amigos I guess do Amigos
21 going into space those credits are fire yeah it
was all worth it just for the credits oh my gosh
that was so good all righty time to get a little
bit serious so around the holiday season we often
focus on getting gifts for others but it's also
important to consider the gifts that we give to
ourselves personally I found that maintaining
mental health balance is a continuous Journey
cuz like I mentioned before I've been diagnosed
with type 2 bipolar ADHD and PTSD and in a lot of
ways I've also grown up in the last few years
on camera with you guys and therapy has been
a crucial part of my life before the channel
even and like many any of you my anxiety and
depression seems to magnify this time of year
still don't quite understand the winter Blues
but it does however therapy does help me navigate
the ups and downs and stay grounded for the most
part and while I have my own approach to therapy
I understand everyone's path is unique and that's
why we are proud to be sponsored by better help
this week it's an online platform that makes
therapy accessible and tailor to your needs and
I know a few people have discovered therapy via
better help and it has been transformative you
start with a questionnaire that helps match you
with the licensed therapist and the best part and
an important part you can switch therapist anytime
uring the right fit for you better help is all
about convenience and flexibility it fits into
your schedule and it's all online so whether
you're looking to start therapy for the first
time or continue your journey better help can be
a great option so in the season of giving remember
to give yourself what you need too with better
help take that step towards your better self so
you can visit betterhelp.com rejects for 10% off
your first month that's better hp.com rejects take
care and stay healthy reject Nation happy holidays
and so much fun Andrew you say your thoughts first
first before I say my thoughts if you could
only get one of those credited films which
one for me for me it's the Top Gun one but I mean
I'm obsessed yeah but there's so many different I
mean also too I'm rooster so I got to go with Top
Gun but I don't know they all look so much fun is
there a specific one I was going to say the Top
Gun one Andrew get out of town um the other one I
think it' be fun if they went to Beauty School
Beauty School Dropout veterinarian one I mean
I'm an animal lover so I could that one would be
fun uh I I I love this movie um I know probably
everyone's like well did you like it more in the
FR I I mean I love them both um but you know I
also love too um I know I said the word probably
like 50,000 times during the reaction but I really
I know the first one was kind of meta too but
I really appreciated just so much how meta was
it just like literally grabbed it by the balls
how meta was but I just appreciate like oh but
also too I love how they called out a lot of the
forh especially with Nick at the very beginning
literally said what the whole movie was going to
be about and what was going to happen um except
we didn't call out the girl the drug dealer when
we were I wonder if we would have gone back and
listened to it if there was any mention of like
probably a new person coming through if we would
have gotten that I don't know I really I like that
twist I I did too and I really like that character
that that might be one of my favorite one-on-one
like with uh you know the main uh the protagonist
and antagonist fighting their dialogue alone like
obviously like fight scene not the greatest fight
scene but the dialogue going on like you kiss
you give me the kiss me eyes and like the dial
I got I don't even like you yeah I got to say that
the Imp I mean the Improv again in the first film
phenomenal but the Improv here in this one again
um the thing I loved again the the strength of the
film though for me though besides the comedy and
and the action of course was the chemistry once
again between Channing Tatum and Jonah they are
just so good together what did you think of the
film keep I loved it I just think it's so fun
to see them like we already knew that they were
going to go to college and it was nice to see
that Channing Tatum's character finally got to
be at college and have a lot of fun but it's
actually I mean it's it's I feel like that's
true in real life when you go to college with a
good friend or like a girlfriend or a boyfriend
or something that college like breaks you up and
you need to go and live your life for a little
while and then come back together with what you
know if you yeah and they really obviously love
each other and belong together but I really
liked the side plot with Kurt Russell's son
how he found um a new BFF and it's so like all or
nothing in the beginning you like find this person
you're like man because you're so used to he was
so used to Jonah Hill's character and then he with
Kurt Russell son I obviously don't know any of the
characters names leave me out of it um that it's
so fast and so Furious and then he realizes like
oh is this wait is this it u meaning the twps a
pot can get a bit of Snooze festy and I like that
plot a lot and especially with Kurt Russell's son
at the end going he belongs with him like he was
so supportive which I thought was great well I
mentioned their chemistry is so good I mean you
got Jonah Hill with the Improv and then obviously
chain Tatum with the reactions they just work so
in tandem but in terms of characterizations I I
also like you just mentioned I love that in the
first film like in high school obviously Jonah
Hill was not very popular he didn't he asked the
girl to or wanted to ask the girl to prom but was
uh she kind of gave him a sign like uh do not ask
me I'm not going to say yes kind of thing and so
it was more tailored towards hey this is kind
of you know it's it's more for him like he he's
like living his dream here and then this film is
now more for chain tamam I do like the whole plot
line though in terms of characterization for you
know they kind of got a break a little bit apart
so they can also have an understanding of like
okay it's good to get a little time apart so they
can see that they do need each other as well but I
mean you did make a good point though that college
can like I mean it's that is a time where like
you know you can you know you lose friendships
or you just go your own separate ways you need
the time apart because there's so many new people
and new things to do and you'll find new people
that you can make connections with which is why
they end up in an open relationship for a while
open investigation yeah I'm like I feel like it's
everyone's story if you go from high school to
college they're like let's have it be open for a
minute um which is uh a great uh metaphor which I
think is very funny but I also liked that even in
the emotional moments like when they're breaking
up when they're like do you should it be open
and he goes in to hug them he's like don't hug me
right now it was as we both said we like we were
kind of sad we I really believed that I thought
they did a great job of making it believable
and not laying it on to thi with it being like uh
extra corny it was more realistic cuz both of them
were really grounded and great actors um so the
moments when they did get emotional even though
it's supposed to play into the comedy slightly
it was still very grounded and realistic which
I really really liked yeah um they did a great job
with that for sure and then also to just uh going
to your point about playing into to twist too with
that the the roommate being you know the did they
by the oh oh Eric are you awake no I'm late he's
pregnant oh no sorry Eric that's a nice call back
uh what I was going to say is uh you know playing
into twist as well I didn't p i mean obviously I
didn't see that twist coming but also I didn't
see uh Ice Cube's daughter and the whole uh him
hooking up with Ice Cube's daughter uh I thought
that was hysterical and also too like you know
we talked about like I love when Ice Cube just
rips into Jonah Hill's so I thought that wasi and
then also you talk about the ending when you know
Jonah Hill has to get into the Lamborghini has to
save you know Ice Cube's character obviously has
to get a little Redemption from him because he's
having a little bit of an affair with his daughter
but also too he's got to stop uh not only the bad
guy but the one who's been insulting him you know
the the uh I guess his girlfriend's roommate who's
been insulting him so it was actually a perfect
uh mix there but then um it also sense too from
that perspective but I just I I loved I love that
twist into uh in there but I thought you know the
film did a good job being pretty unpredictable in
certain aspects yeah and I thought that it was a
perfect ending for me because what he said to him
is I just that wish that we could fly together
and that's legitimately what they do at the end
when he jumps on the helicopter finally does it
they are actually flying together and I liked
that they didn't actually do an exposition and
say it out loud like hey man look we're flying
together cuz like you could just I mean maybe
not everybody caught that but they were flying
together and I thought that was great um so I
would give this my rating for this would be like
seven and a half I I was going to go I was going
to say 8.5 or eight eight or 8.5 I mean Super
Fun movie seven and a half eight around there and
again it it it's funny uh there's some unexpected
twists and uh again there's an emotional pull and
the chemistry between the two main stars is just
they it's they're so good together and a lot you
could tell there's so much improv which is again
it's not an easy thing to do I've tried so much
improv in my life it's it's a very difficult thing
to do so I can only imagine how many takes for
certain different scenes that they had to do or
I know I know watching certain things I'm like I
can only imagine how many times they had to do
that or like is that the first thing that came
to either Jonah Hill's mind or or even the again
the the character who ended up being uh the main
uh bad guy or bad character antagonist like she
had some really good improv skills as well yeah
she's great she's from uh the show where it's
mostly all the three guys they all do improv
um she looks so what what have I seen her in you
know you guys you know I'm terrible at all things
names movies have I seen it I don't know my brain
doesn't remember but it's they're the three of
them they're in the house it's like uh whatever
they're all Two and a Half Men no no no it's a TV
show um it'll come to me she's in it she's a star
with along with the three um guys who all do a
bunch of improv there's obviously a lot of people
from UCB in this uh there was a UCB poster in the
background the Obey poster um and all of these
most of these actors at least the side ones uh
are UCB people that you could actually catch at
the UCB stage because they still do improv um and
uh it will come to me work a I think is the name
of the show in my brain I never saw you guys know
what I'm talking about Adam Lavine and then the
other Adam Lavine is that his name guys help me
out just leave it in the comments I know it's
Workaholics but I'm not I'm not good with all
the names obviously you guys know me by now um so
okay he's at eight I'm at like seven and a half
eight we loved it you got any last words to say no
just I really uh enjoyed it I would love if they
made another one I don't know if they're I mean
this is 2014 so I don't know if they're going to
make another one I know they had an idea a while
back of doing uh the 21 Jump Street franchise and
I think we talked about this in the last video 21
Jump Street meets Men In Black I don't know oh I
would die if they did that I mean yeah I mean with
how meta it got in in especially in this film I I
mean I'd be open to the idea especially with these
two coming back but I would love if they just did
another one but uh well I mean I don't I don't
know at this point I but again you can never say
never because with how many sequels we've seen
come out uh especially nowadays like it doesn't
matter how long you know and I mean this is 2014
it came out so we do have it has been a while but
you never know they could be like let's do it
we miss it I would I would love to see another
one but if this if this is how it ends with just
these two I I I love both these films they're so
good their chemistry is unbelievable we support
it and we love it don't forget to guys to leave
a like leave a comment ring the bell tell us how
cool we are uh buy t-shirt you guys know all the
best juice join patreon we call you super sexy
we love you and we will see you on the next one
goodbye